[Music]
perfect
[Music]
perfect what's up everybody dope azole
here hope you're having a dope ass day
welcome back to the dope as usual
podcast today is a little different
this is the first installment of
remastered redone story times
so basically for the past three years
we're on season three now
for the past three years i've been doing
something called story time on my
dopaziola channel that's my
normal youtube that's where most of you
probably came from and if you're not
and you're a new fan welcome either way
thank you so much so
i do these things called story times i
basically just tell stories of things
that happened in my life
i did not think they'd get so popular
we're probably what
25 30 million views on all the story
times which is
to me is just unbelievable that people
like to listen to me talk because
you know you're like oh i hate the sound
of my own voice sometimes we all feel
that guys and so do i
so thank you guys so much for supporting
that like i said
story time season three i want to start
doing these remastered redone because
some of the first ones were filmed on a
[ __ ] iphone 6.
they were not done well there was no
good audio i had no mic we were using a
boom mic shotgun mic no padding on the
walls it just sounded like
your first rap album it just wasn't it
wasn't good you know i mean it sounded
like this
so we are in this actual story time room
we have a room dedicated to just telling
story time so
we're in the room i'm with marty we got
some joints we got some water
we got some time and here we go guys
this is going to be the very first time
we are redoing story time and this is
for audio there's no camera
we're not filming this this is just for
audio for you to listen to it
on the road that's really what it is
story times i love
if you love movies you love stories and
if you love listening to podcasts you'll
love stories too because that's the main
drive for podcasts storytelling
relatability
riffing ranting friends i love podcasts
i love that so
if you're here thank you for the for
being here for the long ass intro
so i'm gonna get straight into this guys
this is the very first story time i
ever did i filmed this on my phone by
myself
and it's called hard drug confessions so
i'm from merced california and it's the
home of meth
so it's only right to start off the very
first redone story time doing hard drug
confessions part one
and i'm not going to give you all the
stories because in some of these story
time episodes on the dopaziola channel
you can check it out the links below
i um usually tell three to five stories
per topic
but this one i'm going to give you one
story full detail
just here we go i'm just excited to have
a mic that you can hear me the first one
sounded so [ __ ] stupid and it sounded
like [ __ ] it was echoing so
here we go first one hard drug
confessions
so i'm lighting this joint up real quick
um just so i'm not [ __ ] hacking
everywhere while i'm in the middle of
story
let me light this joint real fast guys
sorry i just asked him why he's computer
my bad my bad
there we go okay
now that we've got this joint guys let's
get straight into hard drug confessions
number one
this story is called the first time i
smoked meth and i say first because it's
not the last
okay i know i'm laughing you guys like
you're a drug addict
well [ __ ] you all right [ __ ] you start
off with that if you don't like it
you can easily swipe this [ __ ]
out you don't have to listen to me
[ __ ] you so here we go hard drug
confessions first time i smoked meth
so let me give you the backstory guys
like i said i'm from merced california
if you're from a small town a
drug-filled town what is there to do
you have kids you do drugs and that's
[ __ ] it there's nothing if you're
from a small town you know i'm not lying
so
merced is no different what did i do
when uh weekends i'm just i'm just into
high school i was 14
it was 10th grade i'm a year behind so i
was 14 in the 10th grade i probably
just turned 15 right when this happened
so let's just say
i'm on the verge of being 15. okay so
just to give you a little perspective
and right now i know i look like a
little baby but i'm 31 and i look like a
kid so imagine me at 14 15 i looked
[ __ ] nine
so imagine a little nine year old long
hair in this situation i want you guys
to remember
i would look like a baby so when this
happens it's so much [ __ ]
funnier okay to me at least to see a kid
get [ __ ] up all right here we go
so i have this friend i live on sixth
street and sixth street is um
all the way on the bad side of town i
have a friend named nathan gomez nathan
lives across the street from the high
school across the street from me and
that's where i would
in the future start selling weed out of
the [ __ ] pizza spot but as of now
nathan lives by the high school his mom
is a paramedic so his mom
works night uh 48 hours they call him
like two days or some [ __ ]
so she'll be gone for the whole weekend
so what does that mean if you're a high
schooler and you do drugs with your
friends
you got a spot to do drugs at you now
have a spot to get [ __ ] up and fall
asleep you don't have to worry
run from cops nothing so we go to
nathan's
every [ __ ] weekend no miss
no no miss guys every weekend we are at
nathan's [ __ ] house
so here it comes it's just dudes you
know
pothead kids there's never girls there
unless one of your friends has a
girlfriend when you're a pothead and
you're just like
you're those kids you're not like
bagging girls and shits you guys already
know me you guys already know
that type of kid so that's the type of
kids we were so there was like rarely
any girls over there
the reason i bring that up is nathan
decided to invite people from school
usually it's just our crew our little
hangout homies of like eight people we
all throw in on weed and beer and coke
and [ __ ] drugs and we all do them
together because we're all poor so we're
trying to like
throw our money together to get yo if we
get an eighth we get an extra point four
what are you doing let's put it together
you guys know the struggle so so we're
at nathan's house i mean uh we're at
school and nathan tells me
i invited some people and in my head you
know like the place you chill like
hey that's our place why are you
bringing other people there man that's
like where we chill
they're gonna [ __ ] up the spot and
they're gonna come over all the time and
we can't hang out there
you guys know what i'm saying so show up
to nathan's friday night and there
are so many [ __ ] people there
so hold on let me tell you how i get
there
first time i ever got a taxi me and this
guy ramona used to be friends with
he lived on 7th street or 8th street so
he lived right down the street me and
him went half on a taxi
to nathan's house and it cost us like
eight dollars and that was expensive as
[ __ ] back then
so we have a fifth of jin
ramon just happened to steal it i think
from his aunt he has a fifth of gin
knockoff brand garbage but you know as a
kid if it gets you drunk you will drink
that [ __ ] it doesn't matter about the
brand or
the bitters and what kind of ice did you
use so that actually don't [ __ ]
happen when you're 15 you're poor
so he had that and i go what are we
gonna mix it with he said oh i got
kool-aid packets and i said [ __ ] yeah
i hope he's got sugar because if not
where'd you get some
whack ass whack has gin and horrible ass
lemon
lemonade uh kool-aid sorry i got a topic
let me hit this joint
damn it for everybody driving i'm sorry
i'm sorry i rant a lot all right
here we go but you're gonna i hope some
of you guys end up sitting in your work
parking lot just to finish this story
that's how intense it's about to get so
um
we get i remember i remember all of it
we pay the taxi guy
we get out everyone has the fifth in his
backpack
we start walking across the street to
nathan's uh
apartment complex the gate that's
usually open is
locked so we could walk all the way the
[ __ ] around i remember everything we had
to walk all the way around the block
we get there and there's like 10 [ __ ]
girls there i recognize from school
there's older kids they're like seniors
there
remember i'm 14 just went on 15 probably
i'm a year behind so when i see 18 year
olds there i'm like yo nathan
these fools are gonna like make it their
spot what are you doing why did you
embrace people
so i'm there i'm not mad or anything i'm
just inside like dude don't blow up the
spot
cops are gonna call too many people
anyway i'm just saying because you guys
know what i mean
so the night's going on and i'm drinking
gin not really drunk yet and i still
i used to smoke a lot of cigarettes back
then still so i got my cigarettes that i
[ __ ] got my uncle to buy for me
um i'm drinking i'm having a good time
and there's a bunch of older kids around
so you know when you're like not a cool
kid you know me like
i played football i sold the weed but
i'm not
the cool guy like you have to like love
the
movie step it up and [ __ ] back then and
[ __ ]
love chris brown to be the cool kid and
that's just that wasn't me back then i
was not that kid i listened to [ __ ]
cky and did drugs with my friends and
i was that mexican kid so uh
i'm there and i go in the backyard
because everybody's chilling there's a
house full of people i'm like you know
i'm going in the backyard i'm gonna
smoke some
wheat i weed my pocket and plus there's
so many people back then
if you got a little bit of weed you
don't tell everybody you got a little
bit of weed cause it's all gone you you
smoke bowls with your best homie you're
like yo i got some weed come on go to
the backyard
so i go in the backyard and there's a
dude named ryan i've
known him my whole life not ryan my best
one of my best friends you guys will
hear
him a lot like a lot more this is
mexican ryan this is a little mexican
ryan tall white ryan's my good friend so
little mexican ryan's in the backyard
with this
[ __ ] girl i know her she's a nice
girl but [ __ ] you after this [ __ ]
her name is jennifer they're sitting
there smoking out of a weed pipe
sounds great to me i'm drinking i got
some zigs i got some weed let me use
your pipe
so i said yo let me hit that it's just
them in the backyard remember this guys
it's just
them in the backyard so
thinking about it now this [ __ ] is so
[ __ ] stupid
where where are the parents at for real
why didn't anybody punch me in the face
so
i'm like yo let me let me hit that i got
weed i'll pack it after and she goes
i don't know if you want to hit this and
i'm like and smoky on friday
i've been smoking since i was two i'm
like [ __ ] yes i do
like let me hit that and right when i
light the lighter listen listen to this
lighter lip
you hear that lighter right when you
hear that sound right when that lighter
lit
i put it to the bowl and i started
roasting that [ __ ] because i'm like you
know i want to get high
i got weed to pack i'll pack a whole
other bowl you know remember back then
when packing a full bowl was like a big
a big thing you know what i mean marty
shaking his head right now yeah
it was like damn we packed the whole
thing corner that [ __ ] don't hit the
whole ball
don't don't kill the whole thing two
grains bro half and a half
so i'm roasting it as i roast it
jennifer just says
calm down don't hit it so hard and
revert right back to friday
we spoke since i was toe and i was like
i gave her the look like [ __ ] the [ __ ]
up and ryan's smiling at me and i'm like
why is ryan smiling like that
and then i'm hitting it harder and then
she goes it's a cabbie
and in my head i say i don't know what
the [ __ ] that means
my face on the in reality looks at
jennifer and says
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] does that mean
that's the look i get like huh
and i go to hit the weed and i
as i let it out i'm like waiting for my
smoke to come out and there's no smoke
coming out
and about halfway through my breath this
big [ __ ] thick-ass cloud of dragon
smoke
comes out of my mouth and i know i'm
looking at like yo
that [ __ ] does looks like a white cloud
you know what i mean when you like vape
smoke
you know e-cig vape smoke the big modded
vapes that have like
thick thick white cloud that's the kind
of smoke that came out if you smoke weed
out of a bowl
you don't get those kind of clouds often
you know what i mean so when i saw it i
went what the [ __ ]
and as i said what the [ __ ]
as i said bug she goes
there's meth on it so i blow my smoke
out
and i go she says there's method
and i can hear it in slow-mo because i
can hear my whole future just being
formed like
you're gonna live on the streets just
like your [ __ ] cousins like
no no please and i look at her go
what do you mean this method she goes i
told you it was a cabbie and i screamed
what the [ __ ] does that mean
it means there's meth on top of it and i
look at her i go how the [ __ ] would i
know what that means
i don't smoke meth and then i kept
thinking
[ __ ] for like 14 15 years old why first
off why do you even have
a sack of meth [ __ ] it's friday we were
just in
algebra and now you're out here smoking
meth at ryan's
with another i mean at nate with ryan
you're [ __ ] tripping
ryan just starts laughing giggling i
don't know you like to get wet
and go that's for pcp stupid and i'm
just like
i'm standing there i'm trying to hold my
anger back i don't want to punch both of
them
she's a girl i should hit her i really
wanted to knock her the [ __ ] out
i wanted to punch ryan in the face but
it wasn't his [ __ ] fault wasn't his
weed wasn't his myth
so nothing's happening i don't feel
weird yet
and then seconds later seconds later my
head started feeling like it was
expanding i don't know if you've ever
felt that
like you know when mushrooms you need a
lot of mushrooms you're just about to
start peeking in your head feels like
it's starting to like starting to get
bigger and like mr mackey when he smokes
[ __ ]
pcp or whatever in south park that's
exactly how i felt
i felt big headed i turned i didn't pack
a bowl i turned around
this all happened in 30 seconds guys i
went out to have fun 30 seconds later my
whole life
my whole life has changed the whole path
is now different
i walk back in and remember there's a
bunch of people that i don't hang out
with all the time and i am now
on meth i walk in i tell my homie like
yo what the [ __ ] start telling us bro
tell me you're lying i'm going dude
i just smoked [ __ ] meth for the first
time this is some [ __ ] and everyone
just thought it was really funny and i
didn't think that was funny
everyone thought it was funny and i
realized like yo you guys are all bad
friends
every [ __ ] one of you were bad
friends and i started drinking more and
more and more tequila i mean uh tequila
gin and clear kool-aid by the way clear
kool-aid
it's just tropical all right it's the
mystery flavor packet it's just tropical
[ __ ] that [ __ ] it's trash
and i um went inside i drank
i felt like i wasn't drunk anymore the
drinks weren't hitting me
i started power smoking cigarettes in
the front of nathan's apartment i mean
chain back-to-back you know when you
smoke a cigarette and you light the next
cigarette with the end of your cigarette
you just finished
power smoke i was chain-smoking i was
outside
i started to feel like i was just
panicking i was panicking i'm like oh am
i gonna be up for two days
oh my god am i going to be addicted like
what's going on i know my dad smokes
[ __ ] meth and crank and [ __ ] my mommy
smoke that [ __ ] my [ __ ] uncle smoke
it i i
i can't be going down the path that
these [ __ ] are on
so what did i do take a guess if you're
in the car
scream i'll hear you yell it if you're
in the car yellow what do you think
happened
i hope at least two dudes you fell
asleep i hope somebody said something
sorry ready go
we're back to merced i go back inside
and i start like feeling a little itchy
and i feel like i can't stop moving my
body
like my arms need to you know restless
restless leg syndrome
have you ever had that that shit's real
i've had it before it's it's annoying
it's [ __ ] annoying so i'm sitting
there with restless body syndrome just
like oh my god
is this why you always see people
scratching themselves in the store
because they're on meth
yep that's exactly why [ __ ] are
scratching their body
all the time you see [ __ ]
scratching don't even talk to them
because they're gonna ask you for
something
so i'm like scratching my extremities or
just [ __ ] flailing like when you
[ __ ] spray a spider
like my whole body's just it's moving
around
and i started feeling sick i think it's
because i started drinking so much gin
and shitty clear kool-aid
and um i was moving around power smoking
cigarettes and i was you know
on meth um nathan is with some girl like
i said remember we're not like
we're those kids like there's a girl
here who why
it's usually just all those dudes so
nathan's with some girls i don't want to
bother him and he's in his mom's room i
guess his mom's at work
and his mom has a big ass bed so he's in
his mom's room laying down with this
girl
but to get to the backyard where i
accidentally smoked the meth you got to
walk through nathan his apartment you
have to walk through his mom's room
sliding glass door you have to his room
is only a window you can't get to the
like back patio so i have to
continuously
i mean if you want to go outside you
have to walk by nathan trying to bang
this girl
i know they're just sitting there smoke
a wee but he's trying to make this girl
so i feel sick like i want like i'm
going to throw up i think this is all
the movements i don't know what it was i
need to throw up
i don't you know i'm at a party i don't
want everybody to go
is gonna draw so i try to like nah man
i'm cool you know hands in my pockets
like nah
nah i'm cool you know if i had a
toothpick i'd be chewing on that [ __ ]
look
trying to pretend how [ __ ] awesome i
was because i just didn't want anybody
to know how sick i felt
so i walked past nathan the girl they go
he goes he looks at me like
come on bro why are you in here
and i look at him like hey man i'm just
gonna go to the backyard real quick man
i'm gonna take this call my mom's
calling everybody's so loud he goes okay
cool cool
so i open the sliding glass door the
second
the second i shut it you guys ever seen
the exorcist
maybe when she starts [ __ ] projectile
throwing up
that's a real thing that happens on
earth
that's real it happens to humans it's
happened to people and happened to me
i closed the door and i threw up like
a 45 degree angle up so my puke
fountained and it went
and i could see it like a whole stick it
was like a
it was like a cartoon like it came out
as a whole and it all
flip slapped the ground at the same time
it was
disgusting i started [ __ ] throwing
projectile throwing up
and i'm trying to keep it quiet because
everyone is 30 feet away from me and i
don't want to all come out especially
all the older dudes i don't know
look at this little kid can't even
handle it like [ __ ] i got spiked with
math [ __ ] you
also i don't want everybody to know my
meth so
i'm in the backyard i throw it up
and i'm like no i got to clean this i
don't want and remember i don't want
anybody to know
i've been throwing up you guys have been
in this situation [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you don't don't be trying to
[ __ ] lie and say you haven't every
one of you have
so i was trying to hide it not let
anybody know at the party so what did i
do what did i think was smart
there's no hose it's a back patio to an
apartment there is
no there's eight feet of it's a prison
cell
you know with no top it's just a [ __ ]
apartment we're on the first floor
so it's just a piece of concrete with a
little fence and like where cats can
slide underneath you guys know what kind
of apartments i'm talking about
so just throw up everywhere i can't see
it i don't want to turn the light on
because then nathan's going to see throw
up all over his mom's back patio
so i think it's real smart i walk back
in like oh what's up man like all luke
perry like yeah
my eyes all squinted no i'm cool i'm
cool walked by nathan the girl on him
the girl and nathan looking at me like
the [ __ ] are you doing
and i go sorry nate i walk out go to the
kitchen
i get a big ass like like not like a
pitch it's like kind of like a water
pitcher but like a big ass cup with a
handle on it
and i fill it with water and i try to
tuck it by my left hip
behind me so when i walk back into
nathan's room
when he's on the bed with that girl he
doesn't see it because i want to keep
walking through to try to swash that
puke off
i don't want nobody to know so i'm
walking with a pitcher
by my leg and he looks at me again when
i walk in the room like why
the [ __ ] are you in here twice he's not
mad he's looking like thomas
you are [ __ ] up my knight and i look
at him
yo sorry my phone again you know sorry
open the door
go in the backyard remember it's dark i
cannot see
there's i don't want to turn the back
patio light on so i just start pouring
from one corner of the water
and i have my phone so i turn it on i'm
trying to look this is a nokia phone
there's no flashlight i'm just using the
light of the
luminescent light that you get when you
type [ __ ] so
no it's a motorola that's motorola but
it had a flashlight on it and
i'm trying to look under this [ __ ]
dim ass light i'm like a [ __ ]
slave inside of a cave got no light i
just live here now
and i'm back there trying to just fix
the [ __ ]
and i walked back in and nathan starts
laughing and i'm like
yeah i'll be yeah thanks man sorry man
get off the phone
he laughs at me she's laughing and i'm
like do they know i don't think they
know
i walked three times three separate
[ __ ] water trips remember that was
just one
three different times i got a little
pitcher of water by my hip walked out
there's moonlight backlighting me but
you can't see it cause the fence is
blocking it so i can't see the puke
but apparently the moonlight
backlighting me walking out the door
nathan can just
see a big giant pitcher water in my hand
so the third time i wash down
i come in and he goes thomas why don't
you just get the water hose bro you're
just taking the cups of pictures out
there did you throw up in the backyard i
go no
i didn't throw up bro i just what why
what i just i'm caught i'm caught and
i'm not admitting and i'm like nah man
nah so i just leave i go outside and
this guy le man he's a crackhead now but
lamont
i'm smoking a cigarette outside with him
and he power smokes and that's when i
realized like oh my god you do a lot of
coke huh
holy [ __ ] and then that folds a
crackhead um
i don't know why i brought that up but
yeah i was power spoken cigarettes i
felt super sick i threw up again one
more time in the bushes in the front
and i actually did fall asleep fell
asleep
left just like every other morning left
nathan texts me
one in the afternoon it just says
hey thanks for leaving [ __ ] throw up
all over my porch
or all over my back patio i woke up to
ants everywhere
so apparently ants love meth coke
and i mean they love meth and clear
kool-aid because
these [ __ ] ants apparently came up he
said
thomas there was throw up everywhere all
you did was push it in circles like it
was just
swirled everywhere with like you could
see where water had cut through the
throw up
so apparently i did a horrible job uh
nathan found it before his mom got back
or else that one [ __ ] sucked and that
was my first night
oh yeah that was the night i smoked meth
by accident
so i got real drunk didn't feel the
liquor because i was on meth
if you guys didn't know that meth uh is
stronger than liquor
that's why you could keep drinking when
you're on coke because the the
i don't know it keeps you going for
those who have no experience with hard
drugs keep it that way because they're
not good for you but they're
[ __ ] fun but uh yeah that's uh how i
smoked meth for the first time
and that is episode one
hard drug confessions first time smoking
meth little boy
14 or 15.
sorry my joy went out so
during the heart drug confessions
episode first one i did there's three
different stories
there's three different stories uh the
pcp story um
there's other ones there's i've done so
many drugs i'm not saying like
oh i'm cool i've done it all nah [ __ ]
that i [ __ ] up enough to where i tried
those drugs don't try hard drugs
so this is just part one this is
installment one guys i hope you liked it
this is the
a remastered redone uh story time for
the audio
platform so thank you so much for
supporting dope as usual we might throw
these on youtube you know when rappers
are like
something something song official audio
i think it's what we're gonna do
official audio smoking
so get ready for that we might put on
youtube but for sure
dope as usual you probably listen to
this on spotify or apple right now also
if you got time if you're an apple leave
us a review i really appreciate that
the more reviews you leave i mean don't
be a dick and be like yo this show sucks
don't do that i'm saying like leave a
review
i appreciate it thank you guys so much
for watching this has been the first
ever
redone remastered story time audio
version
sounds so much [ __ ] better thank you
guys for hanging out if you're driving
please be safe if you smoke meth right
now currently
stop that's all that's it nothing else
just stop
all right guys thank you so much for
listening uh i almost said watching i've
never
done just audio thank you so much for
listening i appreciate it
um if you can like i said drop a like
wherever you're at
leave a comment just if you don't still
thank you for supporting thank you for
listening thank you for everything marty
and i appreciate it
we're on to we're onto some more stuff
we're trying to do two episodes a week
so we're going to sprinkle these story
times in
thank you guys so much for listening
this has been hard drug confessions part
one
remastered story time i'm dope as yola
have a dope ass day
[Music]
perfect